all right guys
bang bang i have a uh a very awesome
guest today who
uh is one of the people behind i think
what is probably one of the most
exciting products right now
definitely adventure but probably in
finance more generally so thanks so much
for doing this sir
yep excited to be here absolutely uh
let's just go through your background
real quick for those that don't know you
before you got to angel list and the
venture business there
kind of where'd you grow up and what did
you do before angeles
yeah so i'll do a really quick uh
summary so
born in the middle east um son of two
two immigrants
uh i really grew up in the middle east
india
and in canada we sort of moved around
certain world events like the gulf war
and things like that that caused us to
move around and uh moved to san
francisco in 2008 so
it was right in the financial crisis i
still distinctly remember the sequoia
memo
i didn't quite know i i didn't really
quite um uh
feel it then because i hadn't really
participated in the internet economy yet
but i still distinctly remember that
moment um and then
through the years i i first worked as a
software engineer for several different
companies
uh one of them is now the world's
largest doctors network another one was
acquired by stubhub
and then i really caught the bug and
started working on a few companies so
in total i've started uh three companies
i've sold two of them one of them was
the square
where i was a director there for two and
a half years was with them through the
ipo
and then the second one i just wrapped
up the acquisition of it in
january of 2019 around that time i
decided to take a step back i've been
operating
pretty aggressively for a decade and i
had started angel investing around that
time naval who'd been an
investor in my previous companies
approached me to consider
stepping in uh into a ceo role like
angelus
uh specifically uh the venture business
uh you know at the time i didn't really
have too much context on venture i was
an angel investor and of course as a
founder i'd raise capital
so i spent the next six months really
doing a deep dive with naval
and adventure and also what angels had
built in the venture business because
uh for a while uh for at least majority
of
the world it wasn't very clear that
angelus had a large and sizable
venture platform and uh yeah the more i
dug into it
and the more excited i got and i
officially accepted
uh the rule mid july last year so i've
been in the role for about a year
year and a month now that's awesome um
you have now uh work at or worked at
two of the most exciting companies i
think in uh in finance and fintech
uh let's start with square first you're
there for two and a half years uh went
through the ipo as you described
kind of what were your takeaways from uh
from working at that business
yeah that's a great question um i would
say two
primary takeaways one is financial
services
are basically an unbundling and
rebundling of services
and the second one is uh reducing
friction
as much as much as possible for your
core customer
uh is super important you can actually
build a sizeable business
by just focusing on that one thing and
and so if we actually take a look at
what square
did uh and you think about uh you know
you download an app and you get to
accept payments
within seconds uh a decade ago that was
unthinkable
right the process a decade ago was you
have to call someone talk to someone
fill out these paper forms
just to get the ability to accept
payments oh and then by the way you're
going to pay an arm and a leg for that
square came in and said nope this should
be as
simple as tapping a button and you get
uh
you actually get an account to start
accepting payments and from that
they had a giant multi-billion dollar
business line that came out of it
uh and a brand that people love and they
did the exact same thing again
with cash app right you they reduce the
friction
um so you can literally tap a button and
now you get a bank account
and then you get all of these other
things along with it uh so i'd say that
was
the other key takeaway for me yeah and
as you were kind of
um there one of the things that
really seems to stick out today is this
focus on deposits right once you get the
deposits you can kind of build all the
services around it
i think kind of comparing that to
angellist
there's not actually deposits but
there's a similar mechanism of
once you get the marketplace set up
you can build all of these services
around it so maybe talk a little bit
just about how
the experience at square either helped
or prepared you for
what you're doing now at angelist yeah
it's a really good question
so the framing that has helped me um a
lot and
and what's comparable between square and
angelus venture
is once you're in the flow so as you're
building out a marketplace or a platform
once you're in the flow of a transaction
you are in a position to own everything
downstream of that transaction
i'll use a real example square
started off with just accepting payments
and you know it was interesting for the
longest time
and i was there when this was happening
um for the longest time there was this
feeling that square's margins are just
going to get compressed
because uh uh you know just accepting
payments means it's low margin
and you're going to compress because you
get larger clients they're going to
negotiate their fees et cetera et cetera
what that was missing though was the
fact that square
was in a position where they were
accepting payments
which means today those payments go to a
bank account that the merchant or their
customer may have somewhere else
but because they're in the flow of the
payments you can almost think of it as a
router
sure today it goes to the merchant's
bank account but what if tomorrow
square builds a better product and says
why don't you just keep it here
and it's easy and the underlying
principle there it's the path of least
resistance
right customers will always choose the
path of least resistance
when there is a ton of value also
attached to it
so that i carry that with me to this day
with angelus venture
where the thing that struck me when i
was originally looking at it was
it's just massive platform tons of lps
all over the world
tons of fun managers using it tons of
startups indirectly getting funded of
course because of
all these fund managers um and we're
really
in the flow of all of that financial
activity and you essentially own
everything downstream of it
right so it's just a function of time
and it's a function of that rebundling
process where you can own everything
downstream
so that's a great way to i think look at
it how do you choose
where you insert yourself in the
transaction initially right so obviously
the
the kind of farther downstream you start
the less that there is to capture a
value over time
um unless you're somehow able to kind of
move upstream but if you pick the right
spot
then there's you know a good place where
you can provide value
do it cost effectively and then
everything downstream is kind of your
addressable market if you will from a
product standpoint
how do you think about picking that spot
to actually enter in
in that transaction yeah it's a great
question you always start with the
customer first right
where is the point of highest friction
and you look at that and you ask the
question
are you uniquely suited to remove that
friction
and when we think about friction
friction is basically a number of steps
that someone has to go through
and if you can go from ten steps to get
something done
to five steps to get something done
that's innovation
right that actually is reducing pressure
at its heart that's what innovation is
you're essentially removing some that
you used to take longer and you're
making it shorter
and more pleasant and so uh really you
start with a customer first
you ask yourself is this the point of
most friction for them
and then you simply ask can you remove
the number of steps
in order to get there and the the really
interesting part is when you remove the
number of steps what you're inherently
doing is
you're taking that complexity from the
customer and you're taking it on as the
business
right and there's this really good
concept by jim mckelvey who's one of the
founders of square
called the innovation stack he actually
wrote a whole book on it and i thought
it was fascinating
um and the innovations act basically
gets to the heart of this which is
as you're re as you're reducing friction
for your customers
you as a company take on the complexity
but then what happens is you build them
out because you're building an
innovation stack
to actually create that frictionless
experience so
uh always starts with a customer first
then you ask can you remove the number
of steps what would that look like
and then you add the strategic element
around it which is
where in the process is it right like if
it's earlier in the process
then you get to own everything
downstream of it so it really is a
framework
um that that i really think about as i
look at that
tell us a little bit more about uh
angela's venture and kind of what you
guys are
um building just from a theoretical
standpoint how do you think of
maybe your mission um as a business unit
yeah so angelus really started with a
simple premise it would serve the
founder
it is in its ethos it's just like it
leads right through it's great
um i you know if i just go back a decade
i actually remember
my first office space um that i actually
got from my first startup was because of
a post that naval anime wrote on i think
was venture hacks on the blog
right so it's just it's always been the
ethos serve the founder
and so that has carried uh you know we
carry with us to this day
um and our mission really is to increase
the number of starts in the world
number of successful startups in the
world we want to enable the founder
and really there's three pillars for
angelus venture one is
increase the number of investors and vcs
in the ecosystem right you add more you
have more capital
more capitals available more founders
can get funded
the second pillar for us is to increase
the capital for these vcs
uh so we actually we have a huge capital
raising side of the business
it's massive 40 of the capital flowing
through angelus venture today
are all angelus source lps right they're
lps that we brought by the way it's all
software it's all
it's a platform software all digital
it's beautiful
and then the third pillar for us is to
make it really easy for
startups to get founded and funded we
are
excited to share something on that third
one pretty soon uh
it's just a you know going back to the
rebundling process we are
angelus venture uh is already at scale
and we're in the process of
rebundling across the ecosystem and
really the way to think about
the the entire business is that we
are a financial platform for the venture
industry
and we're effectively looking at who are
all the players
in the industry and how can we build
something that stitches everything
together
so that the ultimately the founder has
an easier time building their company
and so when you think through that today
uh maybe walk us through kind of the the
journey that a founder has with the
product in terms of what's the most
popular kind of entry point for them or
first touch point um and then how does
that evolve as they
uh kind of scale their business and look
for more capital over time
yeah to clarify
the journey on angelus venture or the
journey generally that our founder goes
through
on angellist so for
uh on angelus venture today the journey
of a founder
is really one of as they're raising
their precede or seed which is their
first round of financing
uh they're usually talking to a vc
uh an investor that's actually holding
hosting their fund on angelus venture
so the interaction that they have with
our platform is one of once the capital
has been invested
they're engaging with our platform to be
able to get the capital
uh and then as the founder continues to
raise additional rounds of capital uh
the earlier investors
actually use the platform to be able to
continue to invest in these founders so
there's this journey
that actually lasts a decade sometimes i
mean we have some companies that started
uh you know that raised a capital who a
uh investor on the platform
uh six years ago that today as they're
becoming larger they're going public
we're still involved there we are as we
look
forward we're actually building up
products that are going to include the
founder
uh as a core part of the journey so we
are actually in a very unique position
to be able to build out a lot of
very impactful tools to make it easier
for founders to
not just manage their fundraising but
then also
really think about other forms of
financing right like if we you know take
a step back
equity financing is just one type of
financing and equity financing is really
great for
innovation right it's great for hey
we have you know this product line that
we're thinking about
we don't quite know where it's going to
go great we want to pour capital towards
that
right that's equity financing is amazing
for that but it's just one type of
financing
once you have a reputable process
whether that's
to grow the uh you know whether that's
the growing marketing funnel
uh or it's to you already have um
capital coming in from uh your customers
but you just need additional cash flow
there are other types of financing that
are easier it's just harder to get to
today for founders
so we actually view ourselves as if um
as a as a facilitator to bundle all of
these types of financing
things give them as options to founders
over time so that's how we think about
how the platform itself is going to grow
uh
it's you know equity financing is just
one type but there are many others that
companies can use to grow and we're
actually seeing this now like i think
startups are
and founders are starting to wake up to
it right there all these different
different types of financing models now
that are coming about
and i think that's a very net positive
for for the ecosystem
and so you have a marketplace where
you've got a relationship with the
founders and
as you already stated angellist is there
to serve the founder
uh but yeah um with
the capital side of uh that marketplace
and these lps
uh for the most part um you know from
using angelus and kind of seeing it
uh it's very very software driven but
there still is
uh if you're gonna go and get somebody
to put a really big check in or come out
of the platform with some sort of
commitment in size
uh there's still some kind of
communication there and relationship
talk a little bit about how you see that
relationship between ageless venture and
the capital base
yeah so the capital base uh we like to
call them
their lp's limited partners these are
people who invest
into venture funds and venture funds are
the folks who invest into founders
and startups uh so that's how the
journey works
now the capital base itself in our
relationship with them
is a uh is actually a a
very useful relationship in that
they come to us and they love angelus
venture because they get to see
all of the best fund managers in the
world right like there's just nowhere
else in the world
you can go to see all of them at once
and now with rolling funds because
they're publicly marketable
sas like uh funds they can see all of
them at all
times and really get access to the best
potential deal flow in the world
um and at this point uh we're we're
seeing
uh you know we've publicly stated this
in 2019 that we're seeing 36 percent of
all top tier deal flow uh
we are uh much larger than that today uh
kovit actually uh interestingly
accelerated our entire business
because of one simple fact lps uh
used to want to meet in person uh and
this is by the way vcs were the same and
lp's are the same like if you're going
to meet
if you're going to invest a large amount
into someone you don't want to meet them
right it's really a trust
thing and you're going to want to look
them in the eye and build across that
great am i going to invest this large
amount
and have build a relationship with this
person for the next few years
what happened through kovid was that all
of that just went out the door
almost overnight everyone's sitting at
home and everyone is
uh you know that they still have to make
the investments they still have to
engage with
uh the veteran funds and overnight what
we found was
the idea that you had to meet someone in
person to make an investment
basically just went out the door all of
a sudden people are making commitments
through zoom
and we're seeing this in maps across the
entire industry
actually the venture industry right now
is is is
so active it's actually never been this
active before we're seeing this in our
data we are we are growing on almost
every metric
and uh you know i thought about like why
and
one of the reasons i think actually is
this is that people are now comfortable
uh investing just through a zoom call
and
what that did for our business itself
and how lps now get
with the uh venture funds that we have
on the platform is they'll engage
they'll join a zoom webinar you know
sahil of course did one of those
uh they'll get their questions answered
they'll build across and then boom
they'll invest
so we are seeing uh covet accelerate
that entire behavior
uh on on the platform got it and
what metrics can you share or you guys
have shared publicly in terms of
just how big right how many funds how
many types of deals have been done
uh through the platform so far yeah so
we we've done um almost 5 000 syndicates
and funds so we're hosting all of these
funds
um one and a half billion dollars have
been deployed through the platform
and uh we're well north of two billion
in assets under management right now we
have 47 unicorns in our portfolio
that number is going up it's gone up
pretty quickly and um
yeah and then rolling funds itself is
actually crushing
all those numbers very very quickly uh
so
yeah it's very exciting and so
today um we look at it from the product
suite if you will
uh the um uh
angelus syndicate has been a product
that's been around for a long time
uh maybe talk a little bit about what
exactly that is and then we'll get to
rolling funds in a second but i think
the syndicate was kind of like the
initial
product that people said oh wait there's
something more here than just like a
startup directory
yeah exactly yeah i can i'll provide a
little bit of
context there the
syndicate pro so the way uh venture
funds usually work
is that you you you have a gp who's a
general partner in the fund
uh they go raise a venture fund meaning
they go raise money from a bunch of
people
then they start making investments
they'll usually invest in 20 companies
30
companies and a fund and then they'll
wait
uh you know five ten years uh until the
liquidity events and then they'll
dispute money to the lps
in 2013 uh angelus launched
syndicates and what syndicates were were
effectively
single investment funds meaning
rather than raising a venture fund to go
invest in 20 or 30 companies
you raise a single investment fund to
invest in one company
and for the first time that actually
reduced the friction kind of going back
to our theme again over decent friction
reduce the friction for uh
who can participate as an investor in
the venture industry in the tech economy
and
when that launch that that just started
growing
very very quickly because for the first
time you could actually
you could have an allocation in a
company as an investor and then say hey
i'm investing
uh 100 000 in this company who else
wants to join me
but look the founder isn't going to have
time to meet all of you
but hey why don't you just join my
syndicate and then i'll invest in the
company
uh as one lump sum and and so
that is the concept of a of a syndicate
it's a single
investment fund and
as this got launched obviously one it
reduced a bunch of friction
um but also what it did that was very
interesting to me was
it now gave a subset of
uh the population access to
capital to monetize their access
or their relationships right and so
maybe talk a little bit about the impact
you guys
saw not only on allowing the capital
base to now get access to these deals
but actually the new capital allocator
right people who previously didn't have
a fund in kind of the dedicated
traditional sense and also weren't
independently wealthy writing you know
these large angel
checks kind of how has that um product
kind of
opened up that opportunity for for
really thousands of people
yeah so the way it ended up opening up
the opportunity
is that you didn't have to go down the
uh the previously well-drawn path of how
you become
a venture investor before syndicates
uh and really if you just kind of go
back like a decade
the path to becoming a venture investor
usually was uh
you either sell a company you start your
own like large fund
right so you need a very large lp or you
operate for a long time at a company and
then you join a venture fund
and really there was this hazing ritual
if you join the venture fund
and then maybe eventually you make a
partner and then from there now you're
investing in startups right
so it was just like long uh you know
multi-year or sometimes
sometimes decade journey but then
eventually be in a position where you're
writing checks
because most people in a venture fund
don't write checks right it's only the
gps people who actually have check
writing authority
uh that can actually invest in companies
so with syndicates what ended up
happening was
for the first time people could choose
their own path
right they could say you know what i
don't want to head down that path or hey
i still have a company or hey i'm still
uh you know i founded a company or
operating a company
but i have access right my friends are
starting these companies i know they're
great
and i have access to these companies hey
great who else wants to join me to
invest in it
and what we found over the years uh what
was that
new venture fund managers people who
became great vcs came out of this
um i i could literally rhyme off a ton
right now uh
you know folks who started with
syndicates uh they ended up building a
track record
pretty quickly um and then off based on
the track record they ended up raising
larger and larger slugs of capital to
the point where the reason
uh leading series a leading series b
deals
and so we saw that become the journey
of some of these early fund managers
people who had access but didn't have
the
means before because and they didn't
want to go through the path of
the hazing ritual to them become a
venture you know uh to
become a vc over time they were just
able to start a syndicate build a track
record
and then continue to uh evolve on their
journey
so that went in incredible for you guys
from the outside looking in and lots of
people used it
companies found it valuable uh kind of
the capital allocator the new
uh vc uh founded valuable and then
capital partners found it valuable
uh at what point did you say wait maybe
we should actually kind of innovate on
this model
uh and go after the rolling funds
product yeah
so after syndicates uh there was
actually another moment where
uh we launched traditional funds that's
a traditional venture fund
but the real innovation there was
actually the innovation to
make a venture fund as small as possible
so usually venture funds when you start
a venture fund
there are all of these legal costs back
office costs
a counter cost says everything that need
that's needed to run a venture fund
it used to be very expensive it
literally used to be a hundred thousand
dollars a year
uh 200 000 a year just to start a fund
and by the way that's charged across 10
years so you actually got
a million dollars at least to get get a
fund off the ground
which means your target size of a fund
ends up being very large and
as soon as it's that large you like you
have to have
relationships right so in a way it kind
of restricts access to the industry
because of that so the innovation
uh going from syndicate to traditional
funds was how do we compress the cost
of what it takes to run a fund so
angelus managed to
we managed to compress the cost by an
order of magnitude and again it did the
same had the same impact it was like
great you were able to now bring in
a lot more uh folks into the industry
because guess what you don't need to go
raise
a 50 million dollar fund just to get
started you can actually raise a million
dollar fund
right uh and so we found that uh to be
very powerful
and and effectively it kind of took the
person on the journey right you start
off with syndicates
you build a track record a reputation
and then you evolve and you go into a
traditional fund and so we kept you know
we actually stayed with them along that
journey and then with the traditional
fund they would start one
deploy the capital then go raise the
next one on number two
three etc so that was the second
innovation
that angelus uh that angelus venture
did and this was in 2016. and so from
there
uh you know we've now supported hundreds
and hundreds of these traditional funds
right so we we have
uh over time we actually built uh a ton
of infrastructure
all the way from banking infrastructure
to accounting infrastructure to
all of the software accreditation checks
everything
and from there we still noticed kind of
going back to again the theme of how do
you reduce friction right how do you
remove the steps
we still notice that the biggest
friction point
for uh anyone raising capital is the
process of raising capital it's that
when you go to raise a venture fund uh
the way the traditional venture fund the
way it works is
you basically set aside six months 12
months 18 months sometimes
to just go raise the capital and then
you're just heads down raising capital
taking all of these meetings
all warm intros you can't talk about it
publicly because it's illegal to talk
about it publicly
and then once you raise the capital you
lock down the fund and then
you can't raise capital again into it
for the next two three four years
and we found that the there was still a
friction point on the fundraising side
meaning
you still have to put in a ton of your
time kind of your energy and
uh one for people who don't have the
access meaning they don't have
uh the network of lp's to talk to or two
people who have access but like they're
just too busy
right like if you're running a company
um and
like you're not gonna go through that
six month twelve month process just to
go raise capital
and so what we noticed was
you know we actually just looked at the
core of that whole thing and went
why is a structure this way right like
why do you raise
capital and then lock down the fund
because it doesn't actually make sense
uh your
your best time to raise capital is when
one of your investments has a markup
and there's so much excitement around it
right and so we just we were sitting
there and
and um it actually came through the jam
session with the ball
and naval is great at that stuff by the
way um he's probably one of the best uh
strategic strategic thinkers i've i've
met
and we're just jamming on this and and
he's like yeah you know i've had this
idea in the past
but like and question like why why are
why is this traditional fund structure
this way
why can't you just keep raising capital
and so we we kept thinking about it
and we're like you know it's interesting
the traditional venture fund structure
was built in a world where the
assumption was that people
would be doing all of the legal back
office accounting work
right it was built in a world before
software
rolling funds are a venture front
structure built in a world
host software so our view is that ruling
funds
are actually a superior structure to a
traditional venture fund
meaning if software existed when the
venture fund structure was originally
built it would be a rolling front
and a rolling fund if you want you can
actually apply constraints
and build a traditional fund out of it
right so it actually is just a structure
that is it's a venture fund structure
that's built through software
that essentially has many more features
and you can choose the features and to
mix and match
mix and match the features however you
want
but it really at its core it's just a
venture fund
built through software uh and because of
that you don't need all these
constraints of
oh you need to go lock the fund down and
then go you know and then go deploy and
then raise again go through this big
bang fundraising
you can just always keep it open for
capital uh so that was a real
breakthrough moment for us
uh and and you know from there we
because we had all this infrastructure
we built up over time
uh we were able to go from idea to
initial launch
very quickly and some of the early data
that we saw was was
very very promising for us um and and
yeah we just haven't looked back since
we've just been more than thrilled
by by how uh
by not just emerging managers loving the
product but also establish managers
we're seeing people coming from the vc
industry like wow this is great i don't
need to go through the
12 18 month fundraising process i could
just set this thing up so
um yeah it's it's been great
maybe talk about an example or two uh in
terms of
uh somebody who set one of these up when
you say
you know successful what does that look
like in terms of capital committed
and kind of how that plays out just so
people can kind of tangibly understand
what some of these examples are
yeah for sure so when a traditional fund
raises capital
they're usually raising capital to
deploy over
uh two to four years so if you're going
to raise
10 million dollars you're going to be
deploying that capital
over the four years and
so when we think about the rolling funds
and the capital that that a uh that our
vc is raising in the rolling fund
uh we think about it in terms of
subscriptions right it's
every you know every quarter this flow
of capital is just coming in and it's
just increasing over time and it's
actually aggressively increasing over
time
and how we look at it and and how to
think about it with the rolling fund is
how much in yearly flow do you have
right ultimately
when you think about deploying into
companies and startups you think about
on a yearly basis how much capital you
have to deploy
into startups and that way you can
essentially manage
how you know what your check size is how
many companies you need to invest in and
all of that
and so success and what we're seeing uh
in our data is that
the capital that these
rolling fund managers are raising are
increasing it's increasing every quarter
right i know that there's some chatter
around well these lps are
not going to be as stable as a
traditional fund right
it turns out there you know while some
of them may drop
the the fact that you can always accept
new capital means that some of the lps
will actually increase their check size
um and we're seeing this because what's
happening is lps are seeing the deal
flow and they're like
oh wow you're making great investments
great i want to increase
increase my check size so we actually
saw this through coving
right post post stock market crash when
everyone was fleeing
uh that was probably the biggest test
for us with the rolling fund it's like
ooh right because we're hearing in the
industry like institutional lps are
delaying uh uh you know or even backing
out of some of their commitments
i know of several funds where this
happened and
but with the rolling fund we're like
okay let's just let's see what happens
here it
turned out that the lp commitments
increased
during this because again it was a lot
more flexible right
people are they don't feel like they're
getting locked in for
two to four years now a lot of the
commitments that do come in
are for a longer term again rolling fund
is a structure you can set it up however
you want
and so i sahil for example has his fund
set up to
uh get a minimum of a one-year commit
mlps
right so you actually have the ability
to get this cash flow
or or the investments for a longer time
period
and so we have it set up that way where
you can do just quarterly
or a longer time period and because of
that you end up getting a larger base
of lps that engage with it and so as we
you know as we think about success
we really look at what is the largest
fund equivalent fund
that we we have on a rolling fund
structure and today it's a 100 million
dollar fund on a rolling pond structure
and by the way it is still growing and
it was raised in a fraction of the time
because
what's happening is your daily
activities as a as a fund manager
as a vc is doing your fundraising for
you
right whenever you send out the lp
updates every quarter
you can actually accept more capital and
the other great thing is
because these are all publicly
marketable funds it's actually a
sec rule called 506c uh angelus was
actually involved in writing this and in
the jobs act
in 2013 um because these are publicly
marketable
you can also just every quarter talk to
your lps
share the update but you can also share
it with other folks you can do a webinar
and you can accept capital anytime so
we're seeing
that like those characteristics are
having
this compounding impact on the amount of
capital
that rolling fund uh gps are managing to
raise
and it's interesting because you know
sahel uh he's publicly said this i'm not
saying anything that's uh
confidential uh so it's all it started
with 100k
uh target 100k per quarter uh he he
crushed that
uh in in if i remember correctly it was
literally three weeks or four weeks
absolute question
and he quest his next target again and
he's still crushing it uh
it it it is because it's so flexible
that lp's
lps now are able to engage with it
however they want they want to commit
for a longer time frame great
they can they want to just commit for a
quarter that's fine they can
they want to just wait and see and maybe
come in the next quarter totally good
because the fund's not going to lock
down it's not closed down and the other
interesting thing is
this is their only fund meaning
uh your because the rolling fund is the
last one you'll ever raise
you know you're getting access to all of
their deal flow right so if i want to
if i want confidence that i'm you know
so i'm going to get access to all of saw
health deal flow
i'll just invest in the rolling fund and
i'll just keep investing in it um
and so those are all the characteristics
why we're seeing such uh you know
uh very very strong success with it
across the uh
industry what's what's interesting is um
i think there's a lot of products that
would serve uh one side of this
marketplace right so you can make it
better for founders you can make it
better for investors
um and there's a lot of value that can
be created and captured by doing that
the rolling fund seems to actually be
one of those rare cases where you get
kind of a win-win-win alignment
of an improvement for the founders right
because there's more capital in the
marketplace there's people who can make
decisions
uh much faster you get the uh investor
themselves
now can raise capital much easier right
focus on investing be a better investor
and then on the lp side now i've got
kind of more choice
and also more flexibility in terms of my
relationship and so
when you get that rare situation where
you kind of get you know wins that align
these incentives they tend to be really
really big products right i think that's
what kind of what you're
you're alluding to here is you're
already seeing in the data like hey this
has
a massive addressable market that you
guys can go after
because you're really just making the
entire stack much more efficient and
more valuable for people
yeah that's exactly it's it this product
ends up being a better product for
everyone
involved right and
that is why we think it's actually
striking a card
uh so deeply uh it
net is just very positive because
usually most financial products
especially if it's a platform there's
always someone losing
a little bit right and uh and it's sort
of like a trade-off and you're like
all right well okay fine and you find
that those products
can't really i mean they'll grow but
then because you know as as it grows
there's an anchor of like up the
incentives aren't quite aligned
and you know this product is one where
uh
as it's growing because all the
incentives are aligned we're now seeing
everyone talk about it because
yeah this is so exciting this is great
for us it's so exciting this is great
for us
um and and that is uh you know very
important in building
uh an enduring financial company an
enduring financial platform and
you know what matters most is customers
love it and and we are
you know we're again going back to our
mission we're helping increase the
numbers increase the number of startups
in the world
um so yeah you you hit the nail on the
head like the incentives are aligned
across
all uh all actors uh from an advantage
standpoint uh there was a tweet that
naval had where he responded to somebody
and
uh it was basically you know and only
the way naval knows how to do
a single tweet that you know really
highlighted like
look this is a sass based fun structure
or whatever
uh when you guys talk about it
internally i don't know if that's a kind
of a mantra for you guys that one
sentence that it used or if it's just
something that you guys have thought
through in terms of
what those advantages are how do you
describe it to people who are
considering
rolling fund versus traditional fund
yeah good good question uh i will say uh
naval is very
very good at compressing complex
concepts into
uh into tweet form so it's always great
it's always great to see that um as we
think about it internally
uh the the discussions are definitely um
there are layers to it um in terms of
what the uh like how we think about
why this is great for different types of
managers one thing that is
uh pretty clear is it is like it's it's
a clear product
it's a product adds value for every
single type of manager
um now in terms of
why we see an emerging manager that's
someone who's just starting fund one may
be unfunded who's using it
for them what we're noticing is they can
effectively raise any time they can
start small
they can raise 100k and then start
making investments
and publicly share them if assuming of
course the founder
as uh you know the startup has publicly
shared it and then raise more capital in
q2
or q3 q4 and they keep raise more
capital over time so
we're seeing this resonate with them
because
they're able to uh get started small and
then scale up with it
and our pricing structure actually is
like we made a very thoughtful decision
to make sure that we set up everything
in a way that allows for that to happen
uh so even for the smallest rolling
funds
uh we want to make it accessible for
everyone we're not trying to shut anyone
out it's like great come here
if you want to if you want to become a
vc you can come here you can get started
small and then we'll grow up with you
for the established manager uh and the
definition here
is anyone who's on fund 2 3 4
or they've worked at a large venture
fund and they have a network
the what's resonating there is the fact
that they don't need to go
spend 12 to 18 months of their lives
every few years
fundraising and all they need to do is
get the funds started today get the
capital in
start deploying and then it'll just keep
growing over time
and so the key piece that's actually
resonating with them is never raise
another fund again
this is your last fund you're all set
and by the way we'll do everything that
a traditional fund does
uh you know like i mentioned earlier uh
a ruling fund is a venture fund
structure that would have been built in
the age of software
we're in the age of software so we build
it so you can
create a traditional fund out of it if
you want at you know constrain some
parameters
but you don't need to and so we're you
know we're seeing that resonate with the
established managers which is just
never worry about raising another fund
again this is your last fund it's going
to be your great fun and that's it
and for emerging managers it's the get
started very very quickly
i just love the idea that uh it's so
flexible and so kind of
compartmentalized in terms of the
different features
uh and parameters so that you can make
it identical to a traditional fund or
you can make it something
that you deem is more beneficial right
and so kind of that flexibility i think
is a key piece
uh everyone's excited but what are the
disadvantages like when you look at it
you say
obviously you're you're gaining a lot
here what is the trade-off or what are
you losing
uh by using yeah fun versus a
traditional fund yeah it's a it's a
really good question i
uh it's the number one question i think
about every every day
um i would say
some of this is actually changing very
quickly it's improving very quickly
the biggest tradeoff is it is a it's
it's a new structure
right so if you're an lp um it
because it's a new structure it's just
new information to take in
um but what we found is once the lp
knows
like how it all works very very quick
and some of this is changing so quickly
um and even even as recent as a few
weeks ago where now the community is
writing up
all these amazing posts i'm reading some
of these and i'm like this is amazing
uh i'll i will actually send some of
that collateral over to lps
uh or or even gps and i would say that
is the biggest tradeoff today
is that it is a new structure uh there
you know there are additional questions
that will come up um
but you know our solution to that uh one
it's already happening which is the
community now there's like
it's in the broader ecosystem now people
know about it
um and and every day more and more
people are knowing about it
uh so we think it's actually getting
solved pretty quickly uh and the other
thing that we do
to help in that is we'll hop on a call
with anyone any lp
we're here we'll provide all the
collateral um and we're able to share
that
um so yeah i would say that if i was to
be you know if i'm going to be
uh if i was like really pick one that
would be one
and then how do uh do the fees work in
terms of uh
on a deal basis and then also for uh for
kind of the
owner or manager of the rolling fund
yeah so we
we simplified the fees as much as
possible right
we really do believe in um a simple
model so there's not a lot of fine print
and asterisk and all of that
um the fees are
basically 0.15 percent o
annually of the commitments coming in
and
what the fund manager the vc will
usually charge
a two percent management fee annually uh
and a 20
carry now again the managing fee and
carry configurable we do see
some folks charge no management fee and
a carry
or a lower management fee and carry so
it's completely dependent on the gp and
what they want to do
but our fees are just a simple 0.15 so
for
an lp all they need to think about is
whatever the
uh uh uh gp is charging just add 0.15
to it and that's what we're charging so
we've made it very very very slim
uh because again we want to make sure we
bring on as many of these
uh gps as possible simple pricing and
we're just going to grow
with them got it and then one of the
things that i've
heard um a lot of investors ask and i
actually don't know the answer to this
is
uh let's say that you've got a rolling
fund uh you make a couple of investments
in 2020
they end up being you know the best
investments of 2020 right so now all of
a sudden
in by the way that the world's moving by
2021 they're now all unicorns
and uh i mean you mean decacorns right
yeah
but but i'm sitting there i'm saying wow
like i would love to invest in this
rolling fund
um can i invest and get exposure to
basically the deals that you previously
have done
or do i basically get to bet on the
manager and hope that they go find more
deals like that
yeah it's the latter um and it's the
latter
because that ends up being a lot
fairer to the earlier lps right because
if you
if you allow for an lp to invest
after investments have been made and the
companies are growing
that new lp basically has an information
advantage that the earlier lps didn't
have
uh and and and then it would be unfair
to them in traditional funds it's
actually written into the contract
sometimes
uh which is also interestingly why it
gets so stressful right because in a
traditional fund
uh what happens is you can do something
called a first close you get the initial
capital in so you can start deploying
you continue the fundraising
and you'll have maybe multiple you know
a couple more closes and then you lock
down the fund
and what happens is in the documents
in a traditional fund it's usually
written in that when
you you know when you reach these
specific muscles where it's a date or
something you have to lock down the fund
uh because what they're doing is
protecting against the issue that
if it uh later lp comes in they don't
want exposure
to the early lp's investments which is
how it's structured today
uh in a ruling fund uh the way we do it
is
as soon as an investor comes in nlp
comes in they don't get exposed to
anything
before their investment only to after
what's
interesting is that in vc
um when you have like when you're
investing in
a fund where someone has a crack record
and you want exposure their future
investments
that's actually still a very very good
sign because you have someone now who's
built a brand
they've built a network uh and they're
most likely just gonna get
stronger and stronger over time right so
we see this with some of the best
venture funds in the world sequoia and
greece and
it can build such a strong brand
founders are just attracted to it
um so that that was our thinking in
terms of how we designed this product
again gold goes back to
you know what you astutely pointed out
earlier which is
our incentives are aligned for all
people involved
and so we thought deeply about that
particular piece as well
yeah and then rolling funds are
obviously um growing
and it's very obvious at least from my
perspective that this is just
a better way to do it how do you see the
impact on kind of venture capital
uh more broadly is every early stage
manager going to have a rolling fund
um do kind of the traditional fun
structures disappear and
angelus runs the world you know kind of
how do you just think about
uh that impact and how the kind of
traditional world changes over time
yeah it's a great question um
my my view is that the branded
traditional funds are are going to be
here right they're going to stay
um and uh and i think that
they will continue to stay right i just
think that that's how
uh you know think about that as a series
a branded series a firm series b
seriously onwards what will happen
is over the next couple of years because
we're basically a leading indicator of
this we're seeing all this happen
we're gonna see the solo capitalist
concept
scale very quickly and
the solo capitalist if you really break
that down
it's basically one person with a brand
that is leveraging their brand to raise
capital
to get great deal flow and to use their
judgment and invest in great companies
and today all this is possible because
uh angelus venture has the tools to make
it very very easy right you literally
tap a button you have a rolling font
we'll handle everything for you uh and
they're then able to use their audience
right people that are interested in them
to go raise capital into the fund and
then start deploying
and what we're going to see is we are
going to see
a lot more competition uh coming into
the space
uh for precedent funds and c funds from
these solar capitalists
and we will see some portion of them
scale their fund
to start leading series a deals so there
will be more competition that will start
coming in
across stages but i do think the branded
firms
the ones who built the brand over
multiple decades they will continue to
endure
um because again they have a crack
record but we are going to see more
competition
and and i do think that even at the
series a stage we're going to see more
more firms coming in which by the way i
think is huge enough positive
for for startups because there you know
for the longest time there was this
chokepoint at series a of the number of
firms that are there writing series a
checks
uh we think this is going to add a lot
more people into the series a
stage and potentially even series b over
time
uh so i i definitely don't hold a view
it's going to be
a you know this thing eats you know all
of venture
i do think that there will be a
coexistence for sure and again we have a
very sizable traditional fund business
um i don't uh it is something we're
actually sharing more and more
but it is very sizable and so we do see
uh we do see that side of it as well
um but yeah i think rolling funds will
be uh from a percentage
of number of funds and capital deployed
into startups uh
it's it's gonna have an impact at
pre-seed seed series a
and series b that's awesome and by the
way we're already seeing this
we're seeing some really fascinating
stuff around uh
very notable influential early stage
managers
are now banding together and raising an
opportunity for them right to start
participating in some of these layer
stage deals
um this is happening very very quickly
across multiple managers
and again the the common theme is it's
so simple
right we reduce the friction so that you
can raise
and you keep raising into the structure
um and because of that
what's happening is you're bringing in
all of these
net new people as well into the industry
that just
didn't want to go through that long and
you know painful fundraising process
because maybe they're running a company
or
you know they're already you know uh
they're already
making angel investments they just want
to go through that process but this one
it's so easy
i personally actually rolled my angel
investing into a rolling fund because
i had um i had some friends that just
wanted to get exposure
uh to to my investing uh and i don't
have an intention to raise a large
rolling fund but for me personally
great i'll just roll it into it and it's
easy it was just so easy
so i think that we're gonna start seeing
all sorts of different types of managers
coming in
um yeah i'm very excited to see like how
it's all gonna unfold
i've been like watching sahil's um even
his videos on how he's like posting how
he's making investments it's just great
i think it's gonna inspire
a whole generation of new investors um
and uh yeah it's it's it's fascinating
to see you
i think uh i think you're on to
something for sure uh i asked the same
two questions everybody before
we wrap up first is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
loon shots um it's it's
uh especially important now moonshots
the the thesis of the book is that as
you're building
a large organization uh you want to have
the team that is constantly tinkering
with new products
and the team that's scaling they have to
co-exist it's hard to coexist
it's actually brutal to coexist but if
they don't co-exist
then you'll either have a company that
can't scale or you have a company that
can't innovate
but as a tech company your job is to
innovate it's to release new products in
the world
uh so i just love that book because it
gave me a framework that i've carried
with me for
uh actually pretty much my entire career
yeah that's a great one
uh the next one is a little bit more fun
and then you'll get to ask me one
question to finish up which is aliens
believer or non-believer
i'm a believer uh i am a believer i i
just don't think
that they've reached earth yet but i
just
i can't see a world where we're a unique
special snowflake and there's no one
else
in the world i just don't see it uh so
i'm a believer but i'm also a huge
sci-fi geek so
yeah i uh i don't know you got uh the
ufos you got all these people who think
they're here
so we'll uh we'll end up figuring that
out you could ask me one question to uh
to finish up
what uh when are you starting your
rolling fund
i was worried that that was gonna be
your question uh we'll talk
we'll we'll get it set up in 48 hours so
we will talk
all right let's do it absolutely now
listen i appreciate
uh you taking the time to do this i
think that um you know obviously you
guys are
at the bleeding edge of innovation here
and
anytime that you can kind of have a big
breakthrough i think just in the
structure
and again align those incentives this is
a no-brainer for a lot of people
um so where where can we send people to
uh to find you on the internet or find
out more about
angellist and angela's features yeah so
uh to follow me you can go to
twitter.comlockavlok
and to find out more about angelus
venture you can go to angel.com
venture awesome well
listen this was uh this was a lot of fun
please please please keep doing what you
guys are doing go faster
if again we're working on it yeah i'm
really impressed and obviously i think
that uh the impact here
is not yet quite understood so it'd be
fun to uh to watch
over time but uh in the future
definitely sounds great thanks for
having me
take care